well it's not been a great week I I know
that I should have handled this better I
could have handled this better I know
there are lessons to learn and I will
learn them and don't blame number 10
Downing Street or nameless advisers
blame me and I will learn the lessons I
was obviously very angry about what
people were saying about my dad
I love my dad I miss him every day he
was a wonderful father and are very
proud of everything he did but I mustn't
let that cloud the picture and the facts
are these the facts are I bought shares
in a unit trust shares that I like and
the other sorts of shares and paid tax
in them on them in exactly the same way
I sold those shares in fact I sold all
the shares that I owned on becoming
Prime Minister and later on I'll be
publishing my the information that goes
into my tax return not just for this
year but for years gone past because I
want to be completely transparent and
open about these things I'll be the
first Prime Minister the first leader of
a major political party to do that but I
think it's the right thing to do